TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And welcome to a special
holiday edition of the TLDR.
Green bean casserole
gaining ground
in Google Search this year.
Turkey Baster app
released this week,
keeping it juicy with Android.
Crouton recognition goes HD.
Be ready for the next crunch.
Health authorities
advising against
marshmallow-coated
sweet potatoes
for the 38th year in a row.
Cornbread stuffing is
sold out in all 50 states.
That's our TLDR.
Happy Thanksgiving
from all of us
here at "The Developer Show."
And for those of you not
celebrating Thanksgiving,
happy Less Email from
Your American Friends Day.
Watch your next fully baked
"Developer Show" coming soon
to the Google
Developers channel.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and this
is "The Developer Show."
MALE SPEAKER: Three top
teams are about availability,
engagement, and performance.
MALE SPEAKER: It is one
of those videos you want
to watch the whole way through.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
"The Developer Show"
is where you can stay up
to date on all the latest
Google Developer news
straight from the experts.
MALE SPEAKER: What up?
MALE SPEAKER: I'm super
excited to be here today.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Mo-ney.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Don't
forget to subscribe
to the Google Developer's
YouTube channel
so you won't miss
a single episode.
On the show, you'll meet
developer advocates,
learn where to find
the best resources,
be inspired by
your peers, and get
a glimpse behind
the curtains to see
what it's like inside Google.
MALE SPEAKER: No!
ALL: No!
FEMALE SPEAKER: If developers
aren't building that
into their apps, they're
really missing out
on a golden opportunity
to monetize.
MALE SPEAKER: You're
gonna get janked.
MALE SPEAKER: What
can we do to fix this?
MALE SPEAKER: Don't
let that happen to you.
MALE SPEAKER: Who's
doing what now?
MALE SPEAKER: I broke the build!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Remember
to subscribe to the Google
Developers YouTube channel to
hang out with us every week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]